I don't think you become a scientist I
think you are born a scientist and I'm
stealing this from someone I heard
someone say it
my name is Ellie Max food and I'm
associate director of Business
Development and Outreach at the science
communication lab I'm a first generation
scientist I do not have any scientists
in my family
but I had a very curious mind and I had
a very supportive mother
so I grew up in Lebanon and I Lebanon is
an Arabic speaking country but most
people are multilingual so I grew up
speaking French and English in addition
to speaking Arabic I remember being a
little kid
walking in the woods and then collecting
leaves and bark from trees and rocks
because I thought they were fascinating
um so I always had an interest in
science and it was a good I was I was
really good in school and in Lebanese
culture like in many other cultures when
you're good in school you become a
medical doctor
which is what I wanted to do when I went
to the university
college in the United States I
I studied biochemistry and the reason
why I studied biochemistry was because I
wanted to go to med school
but that didn't work so
I really did not have many choices after
taking the medical exam twice and
failing twice than to keep on you know
like getting my bachelor degree but
thinking back at that time even though
the decision of finishing my bachelor
degree was kind of made for me uh I do
not regret it at all I think that
being a scientist is the best thing that
has ever happened to me I think that
science have given me so much in terms
of
uh analytical thinking in terms of
allowing me to be curious allowing me to
live on two on three different
continents really and meet people from
so many different backgrounds so science
has been extremely important
informing who I am now however after you
know like getting my master's degree and
my PhD which was the time to become a
professor I I did not see myself in that
role I started having more clarity about
what I also like in addition to science
what were the things that I liked and I
was doing a lot of science communication
during that time which I found to be
extremely satisfying I really enjoyed
the ability to talk to people to tell to
tell them about my science and then to
see the excitement in their eyes and
answer their questions I took a job at
the science communication lab where I
would become a career and professional
development fellow to develop online
courses for undergraduate and graduate
students to learn how to give good
scientific talks I believe in listening
to
what other people or maybe the universe
or maybe your unconsciousness is is
telling you they they are telling you
and really following my heart which is
something that I've done so far I
followed my heart and I I think that it
has worked
foreign
[Music]